real quick Snoop because Sean,
Payton was not on
the sidelines. Tonight for New
Orleans. What do you think? He
was thinking? Sitting on the
couch watching this game? Play
out
tasting Hill, please just hold
on to the ball. Ha ha ha,
take a knee, start a milk, the
clock, milk it milk, it milk it
for me. I'm
we got little Sean, Payton
tweet. I'm told right after
they always got that account.
Active. Look how many asses is
on there. Yes, you got more
answers than Snoop Dogg. He's
got a great defensive line
because some boys they were
athletic. There were physical
and they got out to Tom, Brady.
I have
not seen Tom fold
since probably, what? 2007, when
they are with Giants, beat us
and Michael Strahan, and all
those boys was coming after
Tom, but this was a heck of a
perfect tribute to coaching,
Orion. If you really want it,
you know, the players did they
think, but if your coach your
head coaches, not hearing you
play that way.
You've been coached up.
No question. No question. Sean
Payton's. One of the best
coaches in the NFL. We never
doubted that. We just heard
Snoop mention taysom Hill. What
did you see from tasting? Hell?
Out here tonight,
you know what? I doubt it. If he
could throw the ball down
the field. He threw the ball
down the field for a couple big
plays and I was actually proud
of them. You know, I mean,
I don't think taysom Hill is
going to be a great
quarterback,
you know, by any stretch of the
means, he's going to be one of
these serviceable quarterbacks,
but at the end of the day, he
came in, he did he made enough
plays with his legs with his
arms. And I thought he handled
the situation big. He beat Tom
Brady at home in his own
backyard, pretty impressive.
When you say we include
Snoop on little damn. Okay?
Right here. We think about
that, right? I like you.